hopefully it's working it's green let me
check on my phone oh I'm playing game
this work this sound sounds good okay so
I'm playing in the super blitz elite
arena let's play a 5 a 5 is a very
common move to undermine b3 so I I've
done a lot of troubleshooting I guess in
the process of troubleshooting I guess I
broke the stream temporarily the problem
just Sarah was encoder was selected to
the hardware encoder and not the default
encoder so lesson learned but I've also
fixed the lag problem and it had nothing
to do with OBS I have to give a shout
out to just add blue who's a new mod he
suggested that I switch browsers and the
issue is actually Google Chrome I was
using Chrome for all previous streams
and then I guess chrome was was the one
producing the lag but now I'm on Safari
and Safari is is doing well so far and
hello to all the people this is not
going to be a long stream I'll probably
just have time for a handful of blitz
games and I'm not using a new Mouse my I
go to Logitech gamer with every Mouse
she has an unnecessary amount of buttons
so I'm down upon but he has double-a
phones I think I can take and we'll keep
trading let's play Bishop e6 now he has
very damaged pawn structure this Bishop
is garbage
but I still have to prove myself maybe
I'll play f6 soon kick the night away or
maybe Bishop f6 passed pawn 99 it's
going well I saw you yesterday in the
st. Lewis chat always nice to see
returning faces Hey it passed upon 99/5
months in a row f4 is scary it's like
Queen b6 first align my queen with some
targets may be preparing Bishop b3 and
then winning a four I don't really care
about winning pawns though I just care
about winning the King
maybe he's debating whether to play f5
the counter-attack I guess not well now
a4 is undefended
so rook take a for f5 let's do it maybe
I've worked take d4 we do stuff let's do
it
don't really want to calculate I think
I'm I'm gonna beat down the exchange but
I'll have a little bit of compensation
and I'm making him think which is the
most important thing it was okay Bishop
to 84 Queen to 84 king h1 Queen Tiki 5f
take you six Queen take east six oh he
has bishop take h7 in the end so maybe I
shouldn't go into that maybe Bishop here
I'm keeping pressure maybe I have Bishop
f6 in the end or Bishop a6 coming really
no matter what here's 9 f3 and I want to
discover the attack but my rook is
undefended so what do I do now this is a
bad position
not too careless the finite here going
for King f8 night at 6:00 and then
defending the rook multiple times
instead didn't really work out the way I
wanted it to but I do have a pawn for
the exchange I have a bishop he doesn't
have a bishop I also have a lot more
time but I only have that much time to
look at the chat so I'm sorry guys
this Knight is pinned
now I'm threatening like Bishop to b4
probably and he's about to [ __ ] okay
life is good again
maybe knight Knight g4 let's take the
rook first play this rock Queen c5 King
GA - a fork okay that was nice
I'll try and break 2300 this is a
tournament to do it cuz I'll play high
rated players that's why I London he's
Boozer King well he didn't give me time
to bizarre backs and how it's time odds
let me try and play quickly enough play
Knight f3 and Bishop d3 Queen e2
preventing Bishop a6 now I have to be
careful in this line I play 95 right
away mm maybe play f3 this is a trendy
line these days and playoff 3 and ok
maybe he'll play off 6 I have a drop
back Square if I need it play C 3 and
maybe Queen c2 target the pawn happy to
open the H file if he allows it 95 is
interesting I'm gonna be safe 9 F 2
I might just Castle queenside or maybe
I'll just play f4 and make it really
closed and then try and flag him yeah
it's probably a decent approach he's
gonna bring his a night here but I'm
gonna play Bishop h4 but not right now
let's play a knight g1 and then Knight
f3
Bishop h4 up a lot of time I could take
I mean I find 95 mm should just play
quickly I'm taking taking actually seems
reasonable
even though he he'll get the pawn to f6
or not okay now I'm very safe and I'll
just kind of dance around for the next
many moves g5 let's play 95 as Bishop is
garbage kind of this is pawn is on d5
I'll blockade his pawns with my queen
and maybe double up on that file ooh
there should be eight good move I'm
gonna go for a Bishop b5 or not what's
going on he's playing well we can keep
trading I'll play g3 say for a move
I like this position because I have more
space in my pawns are in dark squares
all of my pawns are in dark squares this
Bishop is doing things this Queen can't
really penetrates let's do this okay now
he wants the Queen trade which I'm
probably just happy with hmm
I have Bishop h7 I'll poke around and
I'll move back and then we'll trade
Queens and then the goal is to bring the
King to the Queen side and try and just
walk up in his territory now my Kings
getting to a six it's nice I have to be
careful not to get mated maybe I'll play
Bishop here go for this and be four so
he won't still win I have to be very
careful thinking maybe I'll do this and
go for a five so be careful with my time
too
bring the pawn to b6 perhaps that way my
team can come in and this is this is
actually just winning
it was nice yeah sometimes these bishop
endings when you have an active King and
there's a pawn fixed on a on the color
of the bishop good things happen also
just add blue in the chest just just
thanking you for helping me fix
everything it's so pleasant to play
blitz without a lag do I want to play
some garbage opening let's do it and the
place Stafford gambit if he takes on e5
why do people play d3
it doesn't make any sense just a passive
opening I'm gonna have some like crazy I
really want to take but he takes with
Knights and that would be bad so let's
play well you wants to play 95 let's
play this if you plays Bishop h4 I play
g5 this is also possible nice thing here
is I have a dark sword Bishop you might
play b4 yeah so now we're just trading
ooh interesting move that's a very good
move actually because now I have to play
like some ugly a5 and is gonna take on
b6 and I'm gonna be slightly worse but
not too much worse I mean I'll have the
half-open C file have ideas of f5
probably just castle next
five I'll probably be patient or maybe
not maybe I'll be impatient
yeah d4 good move okay I'm gonna try and
provoke d5 I like close physicians more
than open positions I'm also preparing
rook c8 and pressuring some pawn hey he
played d5 and now the focus can shift to
the Kings side because the Queen side is
completely closed maybe I'll put my
queen on c5 I'll start with that five
Knight will come to f4 it's a nice
harmony here maybe rooks will double off
the Queen will come to c5 everything
will be playing a role in the position
and he's just kind of passive start with
rook f6
um night h3 Knight g5 let's do it
because now the light squares are weak
and I would really like to punish him
maybe e4 because now the nice completely
restricted f3 is a target I'll double up
rooks maybe go for this mmm good move
bring the Knight to e5
so there's some tactics here I think 95
and if you take sigh of Bishop h3 wait
that's just a trade and I lose a pawn
it's not what I wanted
Bishop h3 we trade everything Queen d7
okay I'll do it
what else I'm up on time but I'm down
upon I have some initiative Queen d7
ideas for h1 ideas maybe your h1 King g2
rook h2 and Knight g4 ideas so let's
play Queen here he's a little bit stuck
Nagi for ideas still exists like if
Knight if my t3 maybe I played Knight g4
because I'm threatening to take the
Queen with Chuck and he's running low on
time now this is looking better and
better let's play h5 this is an outpost
he could take on b6
oh but his knights hanging I just miss
that because I've one of three nights
well now I can win a queen do I want to
win a queen I probably do
let's win a queen now these pawns are
targets I'll probably bring the Queen
okay let's just infiltrate start winning
pawns this is weak I don't think I care
about h5 ooh
he wants to make a pass pawn okay let's
take and then take
and now yeah the queen is not the best
black hater start with this this is
actually a really confusing position now
but I think I'll I mean I should be
winning somehow oh my gosh I'm not
winning I have a tricky move please play
d7 yes okay
well it's scary pong was about to Queen
but I made it him first yeah he was low
on time I let my edge slip he played
well take a counter play this a 5 move
e5 is good fighting move okay this is
not gonna be a long stream I wasn't
intending to stream at all for like the
next few days but I was getting restless
and I was doing work which just wanted
to take a break from Reaper 797 I do
coach but I'm incredibly busy and I'm
telling most people that I won't have
availability until like next month or
even like it's gonna depend but yeah my
my availability for new students will
probably start next month but if you're
interested just send me a message
let's go back to tournaments and oh I'm
in 12th place can you answer a few
earlier two questions if you have
earlier questions repeat them because I
don't like to scroll off I see there's a
question can you play the caro-kann I
could why it called the staff Rick
gambit I have no idea ask Wikipedia
how are you watching the stream oh
that's not directed at me do you like to
scroll up No Camello thanks for the 200
bits and the comments how to playing is
d for how to play against gosh gambit
yadda yadda I made this a public study
on the chess it's literally called how
to play against one d4 if you search it
in my chest org slash study you can find
it for some recommendations now I'm
playing the Stafford gambit speaking of
the Stafford gambits I'm actually in the
process of making a course about this
opening and a lot of related openings so
lines are fresh in my mind I spent like
half hour yesterday recording a video
about this specific position so this
should be nice and he's already thinking
so there's a couple like really bad
moves white can play Bishop III this is
not what I have studied I think I can
just take and get maybe taking Knight g4
Bishop III is interesting to look this
up then go after this pawn queen g5 will
come nice thing about this opening
there's so many ways to get initiative I
fixed so lag by switching to Safari I
was troubleshooting with with just add
blue who's a chess teacher in st. Louis
and we were like looking at all the
settings and thinking that maybe I have
to just get a new computer and then he
said I just try Safari and it worked I
want to win the pawn maybe I can play
queen c5 forking these pawns and he has
to play like king d2 and I have Queen B
for Chuck forking the king in the pawn
if he plays King c1 and I made him on e
one so that would be nice okay so now
I'll win the pawn back
and it'll be equal material and maybe
I'll win this bishop double Opie black
double O thanks for the hundred bits
okay so now we have an endgame I have
some time advantage because he was
confused in the opening and I have some
open center files he has two Center
pawns but I have two Center files I'll
just put the rooks in the center I'll
probably play f6 soon I want to keep the
bishop know when he takes all ooh let's
play uh rook d7 now I'm threatening this
attacking this in this so he defends I
could be sneaky threatening this now I
want to push the C pawn and try and
undermine his structure maybe I'll put a
rock on you five lets pawn store him he
wants to play maybe g5 and wait this is
a fork but then he Forks and then I take
and then I'm upping bishop for a couple
pawns wait no he takes on Yeats but that
I have rook at seven what's going on
I'm so confused I'm gonna start with
taking he plays Knight f6 if I play this
take my bishop stuck okay i blundered
I'm gonna have to try and flag him this
is a bad position so nice earlier just
so comfortable but I'm allowing - okay I
still have the bishop I'm down a pawn
could be worse the knight is really
annoying though let's do this
hmm only defense
well could move that was a really good
move no I'm just dead lost this is
really sad every distracted work oh man
so I broke 2300 and now I'm falling
below 2,300 my blunder was pushing too
many pawns too early
yeah SB 5 was a really bad move so
weakens this and then I got too excited
with g6 probably I should I mean I could
probably play rook e5 and survive they
got p5 was careless okay
that was unfortunate I think I have time
for one more game
but it really feels good like no lag are
there any other questions that I missed
I don't think there were any other
questions
black screen again wait what is there a
black screen I look live I think let's
play a London trying to finish solidly
hello from Brazil I was in Brazil once
okay so we have kind of this line let's
go and be aggressive going for h5 Joanna
tries
welcome Joanna I got your message I've
just been so busy it's been so so
difficult to respond to everything but
I'm trying my best
I still want to be aggressive I still
want to play h5 and do things okay I'll
play Bishop d3
I'm just gonna keep up the pace this
Bishop doesn't have a great score to
develop - okay so we're going to trade
bring the knight here I'll probably end
up castling and then play something like
g3 and then maybe do stuff on the e-file
but okay the time situations good he
wants to play e5 interesting let's play
Queen e2 first
he wants to play e5 clearly maybe a
castle Queen side getting a rook to d1
could be valuable and now he's going to
have center pawns but I have center pins
Bishop c4 is a center pin and d5 is weak
if Bishop e6 i25 I don't think you can
defend everything he wants to win f2 I
forgot about this move but I don't think
it works tactically because I can take
if you take some left to I take on e5
gets weird
Queen take F - okay well I'm happy to
trade Queens and just play positionally
g5 is attacked three times it's only
defended once my G for my Tiki five life
is good oh there's Bishop e6 okay
there's still a pin so know what to do
though maybe Brooks he saw a rook c5
ideas of rook c7 okay he wants to Queen
the pawn which is actually kind of funny
but I want to meet him like King h6 rook
takes rook pawn takes pawn and then
Burke h8 meets
like also worst-case scenario I okay
never mind this is just winning oh wait
a minute
is it winning forgot he blocks some
mates
wait this is really complicated now I
got to careless again there's a funny
line there I'm gonna take the bishop I'm
defending d1 so he can't make me and I'm
still threatening mates and there's no
checks
yeah g5 was I think the only move and
now I think rookie eights I'm
threatening made in one and now I'm
winning the Queen back its King g5 work
here that was a weird finish I think I
was I was completely winning somehow and
nothing got careless yeah maybe I got
careless here I mean the safe move is
rookie won I could have also just taken
the rook right away and played with g5
but then Bishop g4 so maybe that was all
intentional and hindsight's let's um
well what's going on here after king c2
this should just be waiting for a white
yeah because it's the meeting that
okay it's 1252 for those of you who
don't know I'm doing commentary everyday
at the st. Louis chess club it's on
their twitch channel and their YouTube
channel I'll be doing it today in about
two and a half hours starting at 3:30
Central Time
people can watch it at just SDL Chess
Club on Twitter YouTube
I'm leaving now because I'm also taking
photos of like the event that's going on
so I will be back at some point but for
now
adios and thanks for watching